[Música]
eu tenho muito acesso
eu tenho acesso à tecnologia eu tive
acesso a visões de futuro
eu tive uma carreira inteira os últimos
15 e 20 anos entre tecnologia e educação
mas na verdade por muito tempo eu só
consegui ver o mundo
segundo aquilo que eu era onde estava o
mundo realmente é o lugar onde eu estava
realmente parece bom porque dá aquela
sensação de que eu tenho conhecimento de
onde estão habitando mas eu comecei a
perceber que na verdade que esse mundo
onde eu estava
achei tinhas e quando a gente começa a
escutar algumas frases como sai da caixa
exploda caixa que caixa
na verdade quando fui entender a raiz
disso tudo porque sair da caixa porque a
caixa só tem dois lados
à esquerda e à direita quem está em cima
quem está em baixo e por muito tempo foi
assim no mundo segundo as minhas
pesquisas tecnológicas segundo as minhas
pesquisas ancestrais seja qual fosse o
ângulo da minha vida do meu mundo
eu estava sempre combatendo a partida do
mundo de forma leve com uma boa idéia
lista
eu combati a os extremos e tentava
entender melhor da direita e da esquerda
trabalhava né pra trazer a a igualdade
entre mulheres e homens em muitas vezes
eu fui dura e eu fui aprendendo que a
dureza não traz igualdade que é dureza
só inverte a popularidade
eu trabalhei sobre acessos ao invés de
posse
pobres e ricos solteiros e casados como
se essa fosse a única forma de se
organizar efetivamente carnes e vegetais
por muito tempo foi uma dinâmica na
minha vida ciência e consciência traduz
muito o trabalho consegue ter contrato
assinado ou trabalhadores livres
religião espiritualidade educação formal
com uma boca nascença ou aprender que a
gente vai ter que aprender por uma vida
inteira daqui pra frente
capitalismo versus comunismo versus
socialismo
escolhi as app's e aí de verdade eu só
conseguia ver o meu mundo e de si meu
mundo e até uma noção de futuro mas ela
era parcial que de novas caixinhas ela
tem cinema em baixo ou esquerda e
direita
eu comecei a fazer uma série de
exercícios sou e como era esse o futuro
do mundo eo mundo do futuro eu via que
tinha a ver com o medo
por muito tempo eu senti medo que ora
que classificavam lado da caixa
eu determinava quilo que não tinha
escolhido era algo a ser combatido
a gente vive um dos momentos polarizados
eu vejo que a natureza do meu medo é a
natureza de muitos medos porque a gente
na verdade só consegue ver se não faz o
exercício necessário o mundo pelo nosso
ponto de vista e é esse medo
ele começou a ser super difícil de
controlar
até porque a natureza de quem tem muito
medo a querer ser muito controladora é a
gente começa a entender que essa dureza
é um lugar a ser conhecido então medo e
duro tem a ver com o quanto você permite
de controle na sua vida eo quanto você
permite de confiança porque o posto do
medo não é coragem
o posto do meio da confiança em 2016 eu
faço esse movimento
eu saio de uma vida aonde eu sou muito
gata pela insistência dela mas eu era
muito controladora seja porque o meu
trabalho que o dia seja porque na vida
eu eu controlava tudo mas na verdade eu
tinha muito medo mesmo quando está em
2016 mudando de trabalho eu achei que
era só o nosso trabalho mas na verdade
mudança de vida era um convite para
começar a acessar todos os lados
tecnológicos que eu poderia como
pesquisadora
mas o presente foi que eu ganhei o
acesso a pessoas também então o futuro
não é feito só de tecnologia inovação é
feito de pessoas e eu comecei a observar
a diferença entre uma economia dura e
uma economia leve de todos os negócios
que nascem dessas novas economias que é
digital que é a de compartilhamento 4.0
todas de acesso enfim colaborativa
ela tem a ver com suavizar aquilo que é
duro confiar e não controlar
então olha que o óleo se lugar aonde o
futuro do mundo tem a máquina com o
protagonista era aquela paradigmática do
tinha muito medo e com o pesquisador eu
ainda tenho que conviver com esse por
esse lado da coisa pra que eu encaixa as
coisas de novo dentro de de caixinhas e
também dessa organização toda a gente
tem quatro grandes movimentos está
infra-estrutura dinheiro conhecimento em
relações
eu vou trazer o paradigma mais duro
depois o paradigma mais março vocês vão
entender o que os números têm a dizer
quando pega o futuro poder p casa
trabalho indústria mas ele pegar um tema
que está muito presente nas nossas
discussões desde as das queimadas enfim
das devastações que a gente está tendo
nas nossas florestas
quando pego essa esse futuro da
infraestrutura pego todos esses dados do
box tecnologia em cima disso o nosso
desespero nosso medo vai a pique os
gigantescos porque por exemplo é um
terço das terras que são livres de gelo
glacial é usado para gato 50% dos grãos
produzidos que hoje desse jeitinho de
50% já poderia alimentar a fome do mundo
também é usado para alimentar o gado 91%
a devastação da amazônia tem a ver com
produção agropecuária
aqui não é apologia à carne a gado mas
são dados e olha que eu conectar com a
versão mais suave disse vocês vão
entender a correlação de quem pesquisa
futuros
quando falo de dinheiro então a
o coração disparava ficava ainda mais
assustador tá 42 bilionários a verdade o
número de bilionários são 2025
bilionários no mundo e ali não tem
religião ali não tem nacionalidade ali
não tem sistema econômico na esquerda
direita a faixa mais de 2 mil
milionários
ela é acima esse gap que a gente combate
do dinheiro do mundo tem pra todos os
lados em todas as formas possíveis de
organização
quarenta e dois deles têm em dinheiro o
equivalente a 50 por cento mais pobre da
população mundial no brasil é a mesma
coisa
seis bilionários possuem dinheiro o que
50 centros pobre da população aqui
brasileira possui
quando penso no futuro do conhecimento é
eu quero chamar a atenção para a cultura
de dados e conhecimento tem muitas
formas desde comunicação educação mas
está às vésperas de entender melhor
aquilo que a gente gera 24 por 7 que são
dados sejam dados biológicos dados de
conhecimento dados de comportamento ea
gente não tem cultura de dados
ontem no brasil não tem no planeta o que
a quebra e analíticas fez nos processos
de política nos últimos anos tem a ver
com 50 milhões de perfis por exemplo
sendo rock acústico e dados das pessoas
de como elas são os comportamentos delas
principalmente dos medos delas e foram
nesses meses que eles trabalharam
influenciaram eleições ao redor do
planeta
quando fala de futuro das relações além
das diferenças e diversas formas
afetivas que a gente tem hoje em dia eu
ainda quero a atenção para uma das
caixinhas que eu trabalhei por muito
tempo e hoje o trabalho ainda mas não de
uma forma caixa de uma forma mais
sistêmica mulheres ganharam com um homem
só em 2047 quando o bota tecnologia
nesses dados da tepco um desespero
gigantesco negri eram como brancos só a
partir de 2039 desse mundo onde a
máquina protagonista a gente vê esses
buracos essas caixas diferenças
e realmente a gente entra num processo
de pânico muitas vezes o medo é real
contra tudo isso ea maioria já só
encontra narrativas que vendem ainda
mais esse processo foi essa reflexão que
eu vi que a forma que a gente vive hoje
existe muito desperdício em excesso o
consumismo na sociedade traz isso mas
existe também muitos desperdícios e
excessos compensatórios em nossa gente
vive uma vida muitas vezes tão corrida
tão difícil que eu uso o sistema
econômico vigente para compensar coisas
dentro de mim o que eu vi de pessoas
mais leves mais migrados para novos
paradigmas de se esse mundo que está
nascendo é que a primeira versão que a
versão da sociedade não se cura e não se
resolve sem a segunda a gente começa com
os nossos excessos pra poder chegar nos
acessos e nas descompensa membros da
sociedade
e aí foi onde eu contei a ver o futuro
do mundo é esse mundo do futuro a onde
na verdade humano é o protagonista
esse protagonismo desse humano trouxe
coisas muito diferentes por exemplo
lembrar que naquela primeira versão a
gente tem muita gente combatendo os
desmatamentos com parte toda de lei e eu
vou lá pra zona de conflito e ninguém
saltar mas ninguém está certo tudo isso
é necessário mas como pesquisadora
começa a ver nos mundiais acontecendo
esses movimentos mundiais dizem que 5%
da população mundial já é vegetariana
tem dados que dizem 10 mas eu resolvi
ser conservadora no brasil são 14%
quase 30 milhões de brasileiros e tecla
e aqui não é apologia do que o mercado
não comer carne mas são os dados que
influencia diretamente aquele
ecossistema que a gente está tentando
combater de forma dura e está sendo
hackeado
pra se ter uma idéia esse número de
vegetarianos dobrou no brasil de 2012
para 2018 fez com que o brasil ficasse
apenas atrás da índia que historicamente
a gente
sabe a relação deles com os animais e
com a vaca principalmente quando a gente
pensa nesse dinheiro do futuro do que
isso tem a ver é lembra dos bilionários
a gente tem três deles capitaneando o
que ele chama o gui pledge é o long que
pede que os grandes as grandes fortunas
sejam doadas e doados de que forma o
ambiente está capitaneando isso cara da
microsoft usa o que emerge que o cara do
facebook o albufeira que é um dos caras
mais ricos que a gente tem
eles estão fazendo um movimento para
doar mais de 90% das suas fortunas em
vida ou a dentro da cela sua passagem da
sua morte
pra quê para ongs que eles estão
fundando de melhoria para resolver
grandes problemas da humanidade a gente
tenha no brasil que fez a mesma coisa
que o l roda cyrela 60 por cento da sua
fortuna ele doou e deixou de ser
bilionário e 2015
a gente tem o painel tais contando que a
sua agenda daqui pra frente foi deixou
times é um é um jornal muito muito
conservador do mundo dos negócios
financeiros falando que é hora de fazer
um reinício do capitalismo e não estou
aqui fazendo apologia capitalismo versus
começo que eu já não vivo mais em caixa
lembra que lá dos bilionários tem pra
todo mundo
o que a gente está pedindo agora que a
gente não tenha mais dois muros esquerda
e direita mas que a gente possa
realmente fazer o que está sendo feito
aqui e aí quando falou de conhecimento
mesma forma que a gente está usando
dados para o mal a gente está usando
data for good para o bem e para o bem
social
a gente está fazendo a linha copa de
inteligência artificial para realmente
combater o uso indevido dessa
inteligência artificial através de um
código de ética
no brasil a gente tem que ter muito
orgulho na nossa lei de proteção de
dados que vai acontecer a partir do ano
que vem
aonde vai começar a ser ensinado sobre
uma cultura de dados
e aí eu tô vendo o movimento de minoria
que são maioria ganhando cada vez mais
espaço e eu tô vendo muito processo de
autoconhecimento trabalhando aqueles
menos em tempos seja o meu seja de todos
ao meu redor
eu tô vendo muitas outras formas de
dança afetiva
eu tô vendo a saída de uma hierarquia
para assinar kia assinar kia é a
liderança do mais bem preparado não
aquele que tem mais tempo
então a gente está criando todas as
formas e todas as caixas e desse lugar
eu encontrei muitos humanos que não
consegue se encaixar mais nada porque
eles querem trabalhar o seu ineditismo
eles já entenderam que mais importante
do que se preparar para esse futuro do
mundo onde a máquina é protagonista
eles querem se preparar para o mundo do
futuro e tem diferença porque nesse
mundo do futuro a humanidade a
protagonista e ela utiliza a tecnologia
para que se ponha em si todas as formas
e soluções de hackear o sistema duro e
aí quando eu observo as mesmas quatro
áreas um ser humano que está ali
hackeando os fóruns da caixa
eu percebi que eles vivem mais lés eles
têm menos dependência de
infra-estruturas nesse futuro eles só
têm aquilo que internamente está
realmente se torna equilibrados e
necessários
a relação com o dinheiro deles nem sobre
ter muito nem sobre ter pouco porque
eles confio confio muito nesse fluxo da
vida é sobretudo necessário e aqui
geralmente o maior dilema é a última
área que a migrada para essa versão mais
leve da coisas sobre o conhecimento tem
a frase que a gente gosta muito que eu
conheci ativos inaugure timbu vai esse
objetivo de conhecer melhor do que você
mesmo os seus medos é onde você vai ser
possível de ser manipulada e onde
aquelas empresas que contém no começo a
gente de forma a influenciar a gente sem
que a gente perceba desse lugar nem a
máquina e ninguém realmente consegue
influenciar ou de manipular as relações
desse lugar aonde é mais leve mas curar
mais suave
elas deixam de ser uma relação de
necessidade que ninguém pode dar pra
vocês aquilo que vocês mesmos não são
capazes de se dar a elas acabam sendo
então relações por afinidade
nesse futuro resolver os desafios do
começa com resolver os desafios do seu
mundo e é onde esse mundo está sendo
hackeado por aqueles que se entenderam
não somente que entenderam e por se
entender não é só o interno é também o
interno mas sabe os dois lados da caixa
também se entenderam e aí o mundo do
futuro está sendo reconstruída a partir
desse agora que a gente está vivendo
através do conjunto de muitos mundos e
esse mundo e se muitos mundos é onde o
melhor da tecnologia não só encontra o
melhor do ano que eu gosto de falar
desde sempre que me conhece mas é o
melhor da tecnologia que encontra muitos
humanos inéditos onde o medo deu espaço
para a confiança e com pesquisadora o
que eu posso dizer pra vocês é que nós
somos muitos e esses são tempos
incríveis para estar vivo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]